the new greatest hits collection for
Queen will not include Fat Bottom Girls
this song was written in 1978 it's been
a big hit ever since was written by
Brian May who's a big lib and it would
appear though the band hasn't made any
statement on it that the libs of Queen
have caved to the woke people who have
said that this song is Politically
Incorrect and that it's mean to fat
women or something like that and you
might be saying Michael that explanation
doesn't make any sense because we live
in the world of lizzo we live in the
world of body positivity Fat Bottom
Girls should be an Anthem except Fat
Bottom Girls is kind of a cheeky funny
song it's kind of making a little bit of
a joke about it but shouldn't that be
positive too can't we appropriate that
term just like LGBT activists have
reappropriated queer it doesn't hold on
what's going on I'll tell you exactly
what's going on it's the Catch-22 of
woke culture